[音楽]
昨日の晩御飯何を食べます
皆さん何を買ったの
そしてその食材が誰に誰がどうやって作っ
たそのお肉がその野菜誰がどうやって
おそらく私を含めて
わからない
のではない
ここに私の問題意識
というのは自ら人間食べないと
でもその職がどうやって作られるそして
社会と評価関わっている
多くの人は知らないし
意識しない
でも実はショックというのは地球環境や
私たちの社会と
密接に関わって
では今日は
普段は意識しない食の裏側について皆さん
一緒に生きていければなと思います
まず
農業
一般的な方法では土を耕して
農薬化学肥料
農薬と科学肥料がないと多分多くの人類に
してしまう
おかげで私たちはたくさん安定して食べ物
を作ることができそして私たちの食を支え
ていく
でも一方で
環境に悪影響を与えてしまってですね
少なからず
まず皆さん文化という
意味に
耳を離してしまういわゆる害虫
でも食物連鎖の中では
文化は不問になれない
のでトカゲは
そして最終的には
分解されて土に
文化は生態系の一部
でも人間は
犬を晒してしまう一回中というところだけ
を切り取ってそして変化を駆除するために
殺虫剤を
殺虫剤を飲むと確かに文化は
でも同時にもういなくなってしまう
そして知り合いに
文化は
農薬に対する
抵抗性を見つけて
そして点滴となった点滴である雲がいない
単語で
文化は大発生してしまい
このように
農薬を使うことで生態系を生み出して
しまっている一面がある
麻薬を使うことはその場しのぎの対策で
しかない
結局自分たちを決めてしまっているのでは
ないか
なそしてご紹介には
ICが先にプロジェクト
を代表して
おります
可愛いです
[音楽]
殺虫剤や除草剤が別れた
から時には大きいボール1杯分ぐらい足が
死んで本当に積み重なってるなんてことが
こんなに
可愛い器を殺して
しまう本当に耐えられない
そして
可愛いだけじゃなくてかわいいだけじゃ
なくて
椿は実際私たちの食を支えてくれている
存在で
あるというのも世界に作物の約3分の1は
ミツバチの自分によってできていると
例えばりんごなんかの果物
とかキャベツが
野菜はミツバチが自分をすることによって
命を
したいのがミツバチの説明すれば数年後に
は人類も滅びる
人類の発明品である
農薬はミツバチを施してそして最終的には
皮肉なことに人類を滅ぼしてしまうかも
しれないさて
畜産はどうでしょう
ここに
卵が
10円ほどでスーパーに
じゃあこの卵どうやってここに行きたい
一般的な要求では金属の
ケージで鶏が買われることが
この1m×1mもう
金属のページにどのように鶏が12は
押し込まれ
そして現場スタッフ1日最初の仕事はこの
金属のゲージから進化
を回収してそして廃棄するところから
始まり
ます多い時には1日1社あたり
約300万
鶏が鶏が死んでしまうことが
そんな状況では当然
免疫力は
病気にかかりやすくなるし
密集しているから
病気が広がり
だからあらかじめ構成物質
長い間抗生物質を使い続ける今度は
抵抗性の細菌が生まれ
その結果現在
進行形鶏がたくさん
殺
処分お子3ヶ月で
割って全国で1000万倍以上の日本人が
足を
このように
この
卵の裏側
は
卵を生み出す機械のように
扱っている現実が実はある
本来であれば
鶏は今で買われている
自由に走り回ってそこら辺に書いてあると
か人間の残飯を食べてそして卵を
その有機的なつながりが途絶えて私たち
消費者の見えないところに
鶏を閉じ込めてそして
鶏の
人間の健康も床下で強力なウイルスを
生み出すようになってしまっ
これって長期的に見て
持続的な法律的な
畜産の話をするなら
牛の話
に後ろを育てるためそして
牛の資料となるトウモロコシやダイスを
育てる私が話し始めてから今までだいたい
5分くらいの間で
ICUのサッカーフィールド
約20枚分の面積の森林
が特に生物多様性の
肺と呼ばれている
熱帯雨林の現象には
畜産業が大きく関わっていると
また牛を
育ててお肉にするには25m
約7個分の水が必要だと言われています
ちょっとイメージ
とにかく多いです
ねでもその一方で今現在30億人の人
が世界で水不足に
2050年は10人より
約40億人の人が水不足
悩ま
されるこれは決してということではない
普段私たちは
お店に行けばファックスにされた
オリンピア卵そしてレストランに行けば
ハンバーガーベイビー手軽に安く食べられ
ますでもその裏側では実は強力なウイルス
を生み出して
環境を破壊して
いる
持続的でない生産方法で作られているかも
しれない
牛肉美味しいじゃないか
でもお肉を食べる量を減らすというのは誰
でもできると
例えば年に
お祝い事とかありがたみを感じるとおいし
さも
そして私たちの植物食事が搾取しているの
は地球環境だけでは
彼は十分な食べ物を買うことも子どもを
学校に行かせることもでき
ますなぜならコーヒー豆の値段が安すぎる
からだいたい1キロ20円
その一方でちょっと私
就活してるので企業名も言えないんです
けどNスレンの工場でコーヒー豆が売却さ
れるとその
豆は1kg3,700円
その分の比率はコーヒー豆のお母さんに
行くことは
あります確かに企業のウェブサイト
私たち
は
確認しますて書かれているんですけど
これ個人的にはあまり信用
できないというのも
消費者には夢だけ見せておけばいいと言わ
れる最近流行りのsdgsになっ
てる
ここまでまとめると
普段何気なく食べている食事は実は地球
環境というもの
そして生産者から
搾取することで出来上がっているかもしれ
ないということを
でここで私の心の中のポジションから
問いかけてくる
じゃあどうすればいい
環境にも人にも優しいそんな
持続的な
農業っていうのがある
そしていろいろ調べなきゃいけない中で私
が興味
を全部
についても
これは新しいぞ
怪しいし
正直をそして今でもそういう感じが否め
ないんですけどでも自然には自然の
サイクルの中で食べ物を作るという考え方
があってそれにすごく共感し
た基本的な考え方というのは
耕さず農薬化学企業を使わず
自然のでは畑の内側と
その環境のバランスを整えるためだと考え
ます一般的に言われて
害虫というのは作物を食べることで
乱れているその環境に対してを正常に戻し
てくれる大切な
存在だ自然の考えるわけちょっとやっぱり
不思議な感じがします
んだろうかという根本の原因を考えること
そしてその原因はしばしば医療にあげすぎ
だったりとか
助走の質疑であったりし
たり時間の都合をちょっとこれ以上説明
できる
そしてこのような自然の
考え方
自然の営みと人間
の衝突しているということがわかり
ます人間の都合では食べ物をたくさん安定
して
だから
虫が野菜をむちゃくちゃ食べてるのって
あなたは自然界のバランスを整えてくれ
てるのもありがとう
ございますね
そうすることで今環境問題が実際に起こっ
ているわけ
です他にも生活の様々な例えば
便利に使えます車運転してガソリン使え
ますとかいう風
に
暮らしの様々
な都合を優先させることで
環境問題が
起こってここでまた私の心の中の
私にささやかにじゃあどうすればいい
じゃあ
環境にダメージを与えずに人間の生活を
成り立たせるなんてことが可能ならない
その
答えのひとつが僕は里山の暮らしなんじゃ
ないか
里山のイメージこんな
感じこれ実は私の出身の写真で僕は子供の
頃よくこういうことをしました
かわいいですね
持続的な暮らしだと
注目を
当ててあげる
そして次の世代の小麦やコハラが育っ
た落ち葉は
肥料として
暖房や畑に入れます
農薬が使え
ます
このようにあくまで自分たちの必要もなく
資源を無駄なく
持続的に使い
ます不思議な時にその結果として自然環境
を豊かに
雑木林に十分に
すると手入れされていない
鬱蒼とした思い出は生きることもできない
のがたくさん住むことができ
ますつまりあくまで地球のために資源を
循環的に無駄なく
持続的に
すると自然環境が豊かに
人の手が入らなけれ
ば里山は
疲れてしまい
人間
の自然の営みの
素晴らしい調和が受け取れるんじゃないか
なさてここまでで私たちの食の裏側が
いかに持続的でないのかを一緒に
見てきてそれに対するものとして自然と
里山の魅力を取り上げました
いやでもやっぱり実際に実践するのって
たとえ自然
を持っていてもやっぱり難しいですね実際
僕も東京に住んでいるし当然外食もするし
卵もお肉も食べます
でも
環境にも人にも優しい社会を作るために
私たち一人ひとりができることがあり
ます最後に2つ皆さんに実践してもらい
たいなと思っているくらい
1つ目が命に感謝していただきます
私自身用法や
農業にもうちょっとだけですけど関わる中
で私たちが何かを食べるという
行為は他の生き物の命を奪うということを
言っても切り離せないということを学び
ました
それは動物であっても植物であっても
蜂蜜であっても関係
ないそして2つ目が目の前の食事は誰が
どうやって作ったのかを知る
とここでお話できなかった食の側が
たくさん皆さんぜひ調べてみてください
そしてできれば誰がどうやって作ったのか
分かる食材を使って料理
三鷹には農家さんがたくさんあります
直売所で野菜を買ってみてください
農家さんのお話ししてみてください
この2つが今日皆さんに実践して
もらいたい
もの
です1日3回身近なものだからこそ小さな
意識を持って小さな行動を起こしやすい
その広さが世界につながってい
ます食の裏側を知らずに
持続的でない方向に生産方法に加担するの
か
はたまた飲食の裏側を知って自分のできる
範囲で地元の野菜を買う皆さんが決める
こと
一人一人の力を小さいかもしれませんが
この場にいる私たち全員で要は晩御飯を
考えることが
環境にも人にも優しい社会を作っていき
ません
ご静聴ありがとうございました